uh when you're partnering with free
delay
on a commercial like this how much is
the commercial sort of figured out by
their internal
agency how much when you're when you get
hired is
can you talk about that collaboration
you know generally the way it works is
um the agency slash client have an idea
um they give they give us me and my team
that idea
and you know we we sort of run with it
and
um try and be additive
you know to it um be
um you know be able to take it
from from the page obviously to
something that's filmed and
edited and mixed and designed and
you know in in doing so that we
you know hopefully make it better um
in the case when it works well which i
think this
commercial didn't work very well it's
usually the result of what
starts as just very good um creative on
the part of the agency and the um
the client in this case we had really
good initial creative
um the idea my shawn lynch
reading them that was twas the night
before christmas
and having a bunch of really famous
football players in their pajamas
too hopped up to sleep you know like
little kids
the night before kickoff was was a
really good idea
and so for for me it was a question of
um making that the football players feel
comfortable
getting them to improvise a little bit
you can see um martin shawn and
gronkowski improv a bit
um zeke elliott and um that prescott
improv a bit
um making them feel comfortable but
you know for for me when the creative is
as good as this was
our jobs are easier we can just make
sure it looks really good
we can make sure the actors and you know
the talent is
is fully engaged and is having a good
time but we can really just
service really good creator uh i saw
marshawn uh uh doing westworld um
and so he was obviously on last season
has a lot of experience in front of the
camera right now
did you notice that sort of experience
when you were filming with him that he
was a lot more comfortable in front of
the camera yeah i think so the first
time i worked with marshawn was
last super bowl spot the nfl 100 spot
that i did
where he just sort of grabbed cake and
and
this tackle football game broke out at a
awards banquet
um and he was wasn't he was nervous it
just seemed as i hadn't done too much
filming
and then uh the the more song that
showed up to shoot leia's frida lays
was much more confident much more
playful and just seem more comfortable
in front of the camera uh i really
enjoyed that you got uh
katie sowers the 49ers assistant coach
to be in the spot
i think her being part of the nfl is
great
um uh was that your decision and can you
sort of talk about how she got involved
i think that um i think i was part of a
group of people that suggested it when
we're kicking names around and
i think i suggested it she was already
on the radar of everyone but i
i weighed in i worked with katie before
and i know her
uh and you know for obvious reasons it
was
great to have her in the spot it's
remarkable what she's doing
in san francisco um she's really
a um you know
a trailblazer she's doing incredible
things
for not not only women
uh who are interested in getting
involved in the nfl but just
she's a great coach and she's a great
ambassador for the nfl
uh when you are filming obviously
everything is different now in the era
of covet when you're being on set
can you sort of talk about what it was
like uh filming with these athletes and
sort of
working in this covet environment we
we're definitely
prepared for colgate in terms of our
protocols
um our safety protocols um
that that included everything from
multiple testings which we all had
to temperature checks to kind of
safety compliance people who made sure
that the masks were on
that only certain people were allowed
into certain areas
that even fewer people were allowed
anywhere near
uh the nfl players obviously nobody
wanted to
nobody wants to get anybody sick but
certainly getting
tom brady uh uh compromised would not be
um you know an ideal situation so we
we worked you know our our behind the
scenes people helga who's
who's honest with us now who's the
producer of it
made sure we had a great safety protocol
in place
and once that was in place it was pretty
much business as usual we were able to
shoot the way we normally do
nobody got sick nobody got a temperature
um we were able to move
uh around the country we shot in oakland
dallas and tampa and so we were able to
move groups of people and
move equipment around um and it went off
very well uh when you are working with
let's talk about tom brady for a second
you're shooting with him what
is that a a few hours shoot is it a
two-hour shoot is it an all-day shoot
what is it like probably an hour time is
an hour
hour at the most probably a little bit
less we shot them very quickly
um you know i found that like generally
athletes don't like to spend hours on
film sets waiting
so um you know we
we plan our plan our shots out very
carefully and we plan our
our days out very carefully when we're
dealing with guys like tom brady or
or any of these guys you know they're in
the middle of preseason
they're focused uh on on football
as they should be and you know it's a
coveted environment they don't want to
spend unnecessary time there
so we were very we were very organized
and got
all of the athletes in and out very
quick time nobody was on the set for
more
much more than an hour and a half i
would say i was also going to realize so
have you already hooked yourself up for
um like vip seats
for whatever stadiums are allowing fans
i guess i mean i don't know i don't know
where you know hopefully i'm a new york
giants fan so
hopefully the giants will let some fans
in and i don't need vip seats
i'll sit anywhere i just would love to
be in a football game
listen the season's about to start what
are your thoughts for this upcoming
season in terms of who's going to win
what
well the giants are going to win the
super bowl obviously
because they'll probably go undefeated
and they're going to beat all the other
teams by a lot
everybody i yes uh
i will tell you as a patriots fan um
your team has been the thorn in my side
um i've been to both of those super
bowls
were you yes yes those super bowls broke
my heart especially the undefeated
season
that was a rough one yeah it really it
broke my heart can you imagine if
belichick goes undefeated this year
uh i think that they've lost a number of
players
due to you know opting out for the
season and i don't
i don't necessarily listen i am very
curious
what's going to happen this season with
the patriots um
just as a fan because i think both
belichick and brady want to demonstrate
that they are great without the other
person
for sure it's going to be interesting
yeah 100
um getting into the athletes that were
in the commercial uh was there someone
that you wanted that for whatever reason
couldn't do it
no we got everyone that we wanted
everyone that we have said yes
that's awesome very it was uh i think
that was a
testament to the creative you know they
read it they thought it was fun
they got it everybody wanted to do it
uh of course i have to ask you um i you
had a huge hit with spencer confidential
on netflix um
i know that they released the numbers
and you know uh it was a huge hit
um i know that you and mark had talked
about making more of spencer
confidential movies
depending on how it went um so have you
guys talked about that
yeah for sure we're deep into the script
brian huggleman who wrote the first
script
just turned in our first draft last week
so
we're we're definitely going to do a
spencer confidential too we're just
trying to figure out the names
got is it do you have a story already
that you're pulling from or
we do yes okay i won't don't ask you
anymore
look you and mark obviously are best
friends
listen i'm sure you text all the time
really close
friends you guys have an amazing track
record um
are you also talking about other
projects or do you think that spencer
confidential 2
is the next thing um for mark and i
yeah yeah i think i think um you know
he's in germany i'm making a film i'm
gonna do
uh something else before spencer
confidential too
but we're definitely gonna do that and
you know i'm sure mark and i will be 85
90 years old one day making movies
together you know
we we're we love working together so do
you think that next year you're
definitely going to be filming it max
venture confidential i think that'll
probably be
um well either end very end of
2021 or beginning of 2022.
got it uh i am very curious i'm very
excited to
you're doing something with painkiller
yeah which i think is a
very important uh subject matter to be
tackled
by uh i i just i need it more in the
limelight so can you talk about
what it is about that book that pulls
you in and uh what that
you know what's going on with that
project
um yeah i mean
the the opioid epidemic has touched me
personally with
through friends that i have that have
embattled on
opioid addiction um of the
realities of how the drug uh came to be
as successful as it as it was in terms
of
the amount of money it made for to some
individuals
um i think is is worthy of a uh
a deep dive um and i really can't say
too much about it
right now um but for anyone that
is paying attention um we have a huge
opioid probe problem in our country
and painkillers an opportunity to take a
real deep dive
into that issue uh another thing that
you're doing which i think uh
uh is very i'm so curious about is your
victoria's secret the rise and fall of
victoria's secret
yeah is that something that's still on
the radar yes it is
yeah yeah um
an amazing company um a complicated tale
um you know it's a a a company that that
is
experiencing tremendous rise and has now
experienced you know
a fairly significant fall for many
reasons and
tracking the rise and fall of that
company uh
i think it's a really good story is that
one of those like limited series kind of
things like six or eight episodes
yes limited series um where can i ask
where you are in the development
um uh there's a um the directors are
gonna name matt tiernauer
and matt is in the middle of sort of
putting it all together
um we will take it to market probably
the end of september at the end of this
month
got it um i know that you were attached
to doing or maybe you are doing
a rihanna documentary and a chris
cornell documentary
um can you can you talk about both of
those projects where they're at and what
was it about
the material um rihanna the rihanna deck
something i've been working on with her
for
almost four years now um it's coming out
uh amazon's gonna release it um
mid mid quarter um summer next year
um sometime sometime hopefully around
the fourth of july
um and it's it's been a really epic
journey spending
the past four years with her and
going from you know there's so much has
happened
uh uh to to our country towards society
since we started this so it's something
that's still ongoing we're still
shooting it
now um and uh i know she's
a remarkable woman who has
you know ev every day seems to to grow
and branch out and
to new businesses and new endeavors um
at a rate that's it's almost hard to
keep up with so
um every time we think we're gonna
finish the movie
and put it out she does something like
start a fashion line
uh like fenty um or
her lingerie line or her skin caroline
um
she's just she's she's firing on all
cylinders and she's making new music now
and she's she's having so much success
in business and she's such a
an entrepreneur that we're letting it
grow but
we are gonna try and close it up uh
in the spring and release it in the in
the summer uh
and what about the chris cornell thing
that's that's being kind of put together
now
yeah so chris cornell is uh is
just a doc that we're putting together
now
i don't have a timeline on it yet got it
this is my last question for you
i've spoken to you a few times and every
time i speak to you i bring up the exact
same
thing and it's going to continue today
whether we're doing a friday night
smoothie
no i wasn't going to ask that i would
but we could we could do that i was just
going to say what what do i need to do
to get a rundown sequel
yeah you know you've got to like
schedule it for
2030 because dwayne johnson's so busy
right we almost did it and we made the
mistake of writing this
setting the script on alaska and dwayne
johnson's character was going to go to
alaska
and nobody thought that maybe dwayne
johnson a hawaiian boy
doesn't want to be going up to alaska
and filming the tundra so we got to
rethink the script
right whatever whatever we need to do to
get
that thing made is